they jitter yeah you can't simulate
stuff smaller than like a centimeter
without it going nuts so
they've managed to nail the aesthetic of
the original avatar while also upgrading
every single visual component that you
can see this is a basic screen effect
i'm going to tell you how you do that
shot right now this looks wetter than
i've ever in like that leather strap
that you were about to say something
hilarious
wait how did how do you how do you like
even render all that stuff
today's episode is brought to you by
expressvpn stick around to the end to
see how you can get three months free
when you sign up for a year
hello and welcome back to another
episode of visual effects artists react
we are looking at some new stuff that
you guys have been sending us like crazy
over the last week and of course we are
also joined by none other than the
legend ian hubert thank you so much for
joining us tell us a little bit about
yourself gonna do this wrench style
hello i am i'm ian huber here on visual
effects artist react this is the best
thing ever this cushion smells like adam
savage's
butt
i like making films kind of 2002 style
of like green screen and consumer camera
but the tools have gotten so good over
the past like 20 years that now doing
that you can do kind of crazy stuff i
mean i think you're underselling
yourself a little bit you've gotten very
good at using this free software tool
called blender and you are essentially a
full-on movie studio by yourself the
thing i really like about your work
you're so close to the process the
entire time you know you're shooting the
shots you're writing stuff you're
directing stuff so like there's this
like so singularly focused world
building aspect where like everything
feels like it belongs before we jump
into your stuff though there's something
we got to take a look at there's one
thing that has been the talk of the town
yes it is called
avatar 2. sam i thought you made it
too a year ago yes and suddenly
it's all the rage like let's see how
avatar two looked before james cameron
got his hands on it
[Laughter]
[Music]
it's a vietnamese
what kind of thing is that there's just
so much going on in the eyes there's so
much going on in the eyes
like the skin like you can't get skin to
look like that no you without cg yeah
property
what i hate is how good this is like
this is actually gorgeous yeah it's
pretty great isn't it you know obviously
i didn't have the team of storytellers
and screenwriters that james cameron had
so i had to rely on an ai to write this
for me the word
is stenciled in it in navi characters
so after james cameron saw my version of
avatar 2 he took some creative liberties
and made a whole feature film out of it
now there's a little more water in it
than i originally was intending but the
visual effects in it are quite good
[Music]
i don't get this but this trailer gets
released and for some reason all i see
is just people arguing about this i just
heard people say it doesn't look good
yeah people are saying that this doesn't
look good they're saying the effects
look dated i think it's impossible to
watch this too without thinking back to
2009 and i think thinking back could be
kind of like altering the current
perception of it too because it's like
oh yeah i saw this back like 14 years
ago but like no you didn't so i think
what they have succeeded most so far is
what you're saying it's like they've
managed to nail the aesthetic of the
original avatar while also upgrading
every single visual component that you
can see i like the close-up shots the
most it's all about like that lower
eyelid where you have that like
subsurface scattering going through that
like pink lower eyelid it looks so real
there is one shot in particular that we
have to take a look at and it is this
one right here this looks wetter than
i've ever and like that leather strap
that you were about to say something
hilarious
this looks wetter than this is wetter
than any other cg water ever this is the
wettest water i've ever seen
this shot right here everything you're
seeing from the blue skin to the water
to the straps everything you're seeing
was generated by a computer and we i
feel like we all we're on the same page
of that like we know this right yeah so
why does the internet refuse to believe
that that shot is generated by a
computer i think because for the past
like you know 15 20 years of seeing a
lot of cg water we're always seeing it
this scale the wide scale yeah because
that's actually fairly easy and like we
figured out how to do large scale
simulations but we never see like this
micro stuff like if you look there's one
frame where it tugs and like that's
displaced to the water splashing up
outside of the saddle like in one frame
and we never see that type of like
dramatic small scale stuff it's a normal
question why not just shoot that
practically why would you want to shoot
a random close-up practical in this
movie where almost everything else is cg
just before you even look at the shot
just say james cameron made a movie with
99 cg shots in it
and then and go but one might be real
and you're like the lion king the first
shot's like an actual shot of you know a
sunrise in africa and then cg after that
there you go that's an explanation but
not like
a bootstrap
the reason why you wouldn't shoot this
practically is it really comes down to
consistency you know you already have
these super high fidelity 3d models of
these blue alien 10 foot tall people it
doesn't really make sense to shoot them
practically because you're going to get
like a sort of mix up of scale and it
might also just look different from
everything else that you're also putting
in the movie second question
how do we know that this is cg we know
that the navi person is cg because it's
clear that that is not paint on the skin
that is actual cg skin the only way if
you're gonna let's say do navi makeup on
someone and make it look this good you
basically have to like tattoo or like
dye their skin yeah actually you'd have
to tattoo them because when you put on
paint you're basically
covering up all the actual
characteristics of skin so to speak the
light bounces off the paint versus going
into your skin and then illuminating it
as
skin does since it's slightly
translucent so then they're like but the
water there's no possible way water
simulations are that good people are
asking why wouldn't you just like do a
cg character in real water and it's
because water is mostly defined by what
it's reflecting and what it's refracting
you'd have to paint out the original
person from the reflection in every
single wavelet which is a huge thing and
also you have to paint out the
refraction of like what's and then
what's left of the water it's all just
reflections and refraction there's
nothing left and then trying to put a
different digital character in there
with that same offsets is crazy yeah the
bit that i think is nuts with this is
the surface tension in the bottom left
the way it goes into that woven bit yes
okay yeah surface and i was gonna point
out on the right i don't remember ever
seeing surface tension on that complex
and dynamic of a scale like as the water
goes away it's still trapped there in
the little bits i'm like is this a 20
terabyte simulation or have they figured
out some wacky stuff within this movie
there's like so many huge achievements
that we're probably going to be able to
see or leaps forward with technology
everything from like all the underwater
filming they did underwater mocap they
figured out how to do that they like
have ever all the actors learn how to
free dive and hold their breath for like
10 or 15 minutes is it true yes they're
like literally like insane things just
from like an acting and mocap standpoint
yeah but then on top of that from like a
visual and rendering standpoint there's
like i don't even know how many patents
they've been making but i've seen little
blurbs pop up like oh cool wade has got
like four or five new like water
simulation patents for like really
unique cases like this shop i have their
patent pulled up right here method for
generating simulations of thin film
interfaces for improved animation what
is this yeah i think what it's doing is
there's a two stage water simulation
happening right here normally when you
do a water stem it's very particle based
and they're doing that first particle
stem for the water but then when it
actually like interfaces with something
i think what it's saying is that it's
actually generating new particles at
those actual surfaces and that's kind of
creating the illusion of that water
tension that you're talking about so
basically they it's they figure out how
to make stuff look really wet
that's what it is it's the wet filter
juetta is famous for literally inventing
tools from scratch in order to make
their movies remember back when like
massive armies weren't a thing and then
peter jackson was like i want an army i
want 10 000 people but they also
pioneered the whole animation pipeline
for creatures so it does not surprise me
that they are making even more strides
with brand new tools for the water stuff
we open this with the idea that there's
like people arguing on the internet
about it but frankly i think that's just
a few people with loud voices i think
most people who saw this were like this
is dope and i you know i think that you
know because it's pretty obvious you
know what i think it's time
for you to pull the trigger and hit that
subscribe button look if we hit 100
subscribers we'll shut up but until then
we have to keep saying this stuff
because youtube demands it i would be
remiss if we did not actually look at
some of your incredible films that
you've put out with you here on the
couch right now we had you in before
long distance but we see it together
let's look at it right after the avatar
2 trailer
that's going to
really make it shine
dude i like how your stuff always opens
with like a fisheye lens i've gone so
hard in the fisheye on the recent stuff
yeah i know it's nice it's a nice touch
the sheer amount of detail you get in
the texture work has always blown me
away did you hand model each of those
jet engines i modeled a lot of different
pieces i made a little library of stuff
and yeah i kind of have one jet engine
and i would wrap it in different things
and you can see they're kind of the same
like i've mixed and matched a little bit
but they're mostly just the same over
and over because those aren't the main
details you're looking at and so it's
like all right that illusion of crazy
detail this shot right here if you look
at the connections between like the foot
and the panel in the back all those
linkages are an ik chain and so i'm just
trying to show off where i actually do
have detail and distract from the places
where i don't that's a great shot it's
it's an incredible shot the popcorn
machine i think is a great example look
at that like
dank we're back to the moistness you
know like the reason though there's a
big cool popcorn bot in the foreground
is because i'm trying to distract you
from the janky people right behind it
and that's the whole deal oh you're
right those are super jams yeah so but
everybody's looking at the popcorn robot
because i know how to do robots
wait how do you how do you like even
render all that stuff
i mean i mean like
i just look at the complexity here and
it's like do your project files even
work it's all hand modeled and because i
learned modeling in the 90s where you
get you know a thousand polygons in
there and your computer slows to a chug
but in general it's low poly stuff with
image textures on there kind of like
trying to sell the texture so like the
ground there and the walls very low poly
those are yeah those are low polygon
surfaces but high detail image textures
on top of them kind of giving the
illusion of a lot more detail and
because of the motion blur they're not
even high resolution textures
and again i'm putting in all of these
lights passing by to like add to the
sense of speed but also to make it so
you never really get to look at anything
properly it's all psychological
basically before somebody can fully
appreciate the thing you whip away so
that they're like oh there's too much to
experience and it's like yeah because
you only had a quarter of a second to
look at it
they jitter
jitteros sorry hold on whoa hype
jittering
is that the best
cd joke ever it is the best cg is that
just the worst physics sim yeah yeah you
can't simulate stuff smaller than like a
centimeter without it going nuts so
because it's an actual thing like like
these things and sometimes like they
just they jitter they don't stop and you
incorporated that into the thing by
making a joke the reason why i love this
is because it's like a triple entendre
you got a hyper bowl it's a hyperbole
and then you got a hyper bowl a cereal
let's wind the clock back a little more
1924
okay 98 years ago all right everyone
you're struggling to make a video
98 years ago they had it all figured
this is the third film
ever made
dude
all right this is obviously double
exposure yeah but he's see through why
isn't the guy on the right see through
if it's double exposure he's see-through
you double expose it but when he gets up
that should also be revealing the
environment that he just left yeah see
now the problem is is that these guys
are fifty percent of packages they're
also see-through see how they're
see-through two now
yeah see that's the problem i'm gonna
tell you how you do that shot right now
this is a basic screen effect you're on
a set what we're seeing here is
basically he's sitting on a stool and
when they get the second take of him
waking up they turn off some lights they
move the walls back they clear it and
they probably even just put like some
black felt over that you can see the
felt fade in on the left it looks like
cobwebs and like around the safe and
like that's just the curved black velvet
that they put over the set so they
wouldn't be exposing the background yeah
they just put fabric over everything
yeah exactly because this is a double
exposure they're doing this on the same
exact original film and so anything that
is bright enough to expose the film will
be seen again it's like the original og
way to do green screening except it was
just pure brightness values
wait i thought that was no that's a real
set there that was a real set i thought
that was a picture-in-picture type deal
with like a freaking matted out double
exposure type type thing which is where
i love this old stuff just because like
so much of it is so obvious but it's
just so well done
[Music]
that was a classic hard cut and they
just swapped out the set says everybody
tried to stay still all right let's see
let's see let's see so the tell here
usually is watch the specific position
of the audience
yeah they do
wait a second though hold on that's not
the set though that's that's like a
composite though this is probably
something where they have to expose this
later was it more common in what 1924
for them to just do this in camera or
was this something that they were doing
but back at like a like a film lab
because if you were to do this in camera
think about the process you film your
opera scene with a black area there and
then basically you hike out to a
mountain with a film reel full of people
at this theater oh i see what you're
saying i bet you're totally right and
then you somehow mat off your footage in
camera to line up with that that doesn't
seem very practical this might be a
thing where we need to call in an expert
let's use our lifeline okay
nico
hey nico can you hear us
help
nico
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
buster keaton it means you bust a fact
we just don't know the specifics of how
would they have composited two different
elements because they're compositing
like a movie into this theater so i'm
gonna guess that this is a two pieces of
film layered on top of each other in the
editing bay the use of the heavy black
border around the staging area it lends
itself to then just blacking out the
entire thing and having a chunk of
unexposed film you can stick another
piece of film on top of it and just
shoot through both of them onto a final
piece of film it's not that they're
double exposing the film they're taking
two sets of film and exposing a third
set of film the reason i'm going to
suggest that is because of how much more
contrasty the background becomes yeah
see how it gets really dark in like the
blacks get really mushed if they just
did a second exposure on it the
background like dark elements should
stay normal it should look nice you know
it's not being double exposed through
another set of film and that's why now
that it's a practical set we get those
black levels back so techniques is not a
double exposure this is a optical
printed stack in my guess there's a
double exposure everything else should
still look nice and you just have the
exposure in the center i mean the
problem solving that just had to exist
back in the day in order to achieve this
stuff is nuts
[Music]
there wasn't a cut they were moving
continuously the whole time that
happened are you sure there wasn't a cut
i mean let's watch him there's a match
cut boom
no that
the exposure jumps there's a bump in the
exposure like there's a cut there's a
cut watch the guy on the right the guy
on the left is still moving at that
moment though like his arms are swinging
perfectly into position i think he's up
he's gonna say the same thing yeah he's
jumping through and you can see he's
laying down his wing in
into the costume i think he's like
laying down on like a diving board type
thing and he pops in and then as soon as
he goes through his body comes down and
his arms are there too and so it's like
his arm and his head are there but his
body is going out backwards so that's
how he can get through there and then he
comes in that doesn't mean that there
can't be a jump cut though i just
matching the arm movement would be
they've not demonstrated that they can
do that particularly well i think you're
right i think there's a really fancy
practical thing happening i think
there's a little bit of editing
happening and notice how he reaches back
around and like holds the dress together
behind him as he walks away oh yeah
oh yeah that's totally it
and he wouldn't need to do that if it
was just a match cut i remember watching
this as like a teenager and just being
like how did they do that you know what
i take it back there might be a small
cut in there but for all intents and
purposes this is done practically was
this term when they were manual cranking
so could they have slowed down the
cranking for just right then to help the
effect happen and then they speed it
back up but if it was a slower crank
wouldn't that create a more exposure
which would explain the exposure bump
dude to be so good at cranking just be
like and go and just like right into it
smoothly again wait nico you had
something else you wanted to show right
yeah so one of the things of my little
guest appearance here in this episode is
uh so this new kendrick lamar music
video dropped with an insane d vake we
got a ton of requests to talk about it
unfortunately we can't talk about music
video on youtube because then
immediately the channel gets copyright
stricken copyright struck and i don't
know so yeah it's on our website
quarterdigital.com i will delve into
this and break it down for you there if
you want to check it out all right well
that's all i have to say about that sam
you can stop hiding behind the couch now
all right see you guys
you may have seen a lot of amazing
things on this show but one thing you
haven't seen is what's about to happen
right now that's right courtesy of
today's sponsor expressvpn i will be
riding this child's bicycle while also
telling you about the wonders of how to
protect your internet data let's get
started you see the first thing you've
got to know is when your data is out on
the open internet it's it's not exactly
that safe it's susceptible to hackers
third-party advertisers either buying or
buying or stealing your information and
that's really not good and a vpn
provides an additional layer of
encryption so that your data is
protected as it's out on the open
internet the best part is that through
using a vpn like expressvpn you can get
content that might not otherwise be
available in your country or region how
does that work jake well it's actually
very simple you see a vpn tells the open
internet that you're accessing the
internet from an entirely different
location which allows you to access
content on say
netflix that's available
in england
and not in the united states that means
that you can get things like oh i don't
know the entire studio ghibli library
which isn't available on netflix us but
is available in other countries just by
using expressvpn expressvpn has been
rated number one vpn service by forbes
and techradar and they have servers in
over 94 countries anyways if you guys
are interested in getting expressvpn for
yourself
and getting three months free of that
service all you have to do is click the
link in the description below or go to
expressvpn.com
corridor crew
that's right just click the link in the
description below or go to
expressvpn.com
slash corridor crew to see how you can
get three months free when you sign up
for a year you're probably thanking me
right now so you're welcome see you
later tah
and uh
toodaloo
hey if there's some cool wet clips you
want us to check out let us know in the
comments below i feel like we missed
some moist clips dude it can get wetter
here
what a
wet day oh my god
with the wettest effects
all right
this was actually a huge amount of fun
ian i have been looking forward to
having you on the couch for literally
years i've been looking forward to it
also i'm using your energy again okay
great
you have a youtube channel you have a
patreon people can go check out your
stuff right now everything i've put up
for the past few years has been on my
patreon where i literally explain break
all of this down uh little tutorials
yeah go watch the stuff there's links
everywhere in the description or up and
down they're in the screen thanks
everyone for watching don't forget to
smash that like button and hit subscribe
on ian's youtube channel and uh we'll
see you guys in the next episode